wir alle ganze generationen saßen mit
ihm in einem boot in diesem boot das
boot
das war sein fehlen des lebens
der film von wolfgang peters
das macht gänsehaut
wir trauern heute um ihn um unser star
regisseur wolfgang petersen
denn er hatte es wirklich geschafft als
deutsche in hollywood
wolfgang petersson gestorben mit 81
jahren an krebs der mann also mit dem
wir alle hinten boot saßen wir trauern
um deutschlands kommandeure und um ihn
und auch er kann sehr wolfgang petersen
hat viele stunden mit ihm verbracht mit
hollywood reporter norbert körzdörfer
der songs jetzt live zugeschaltet gehen
erst wir gehen erst unsere kollegen denn
alle die ganze u boot wählt die trauert
heute um wolfgang petersson auch die die
tatsächlich ein u boot gesteuert haben
ich grüße sie ganz herzlich an unser
bild u boot kommandant noch heute früh
herzlich willkommen bei bild live
wie trauern sie heute um wolfgang
petersson um den mann mit dem wir alle
im boot saßen
ja ich habe wolfgang petersen hat es
große freude ihnen persönlich zu
begegnen
das heißt mit großem abstand ich kann
nicht sagen dass wir uns kennen aber es
war bei den filmfestspielen bei der
bavaria
2009 10 da wurde die eine halle bei der
bavaria in die wolf kp lassen also
umbenannt und das war für mich sehr
ergreifend muss ich sagen diesen vitalen
und wir gehen ja auch schon auf die auf
die 80 gut zu so offen und so so frei
reden zu hören es war eine freude ihm
zuzuhören
fregattenkapitän weber was hat wolfgang
petersson für sie gemacht für ja dafür
dass wir alle wir alle deutschen so
tiefe einblicke in das u boot bekommen
haben
ich finde er hat dieses buch von buch
sehr sehr gut umgesetzt und
wir waren nur 82 83 mit neun fahrern im
kino haben den fehlen gesehen und für
unseren breiten schultern waren die kino
türen viel zu schmal als wir wieder
rausgehen
es war also ja er hat den u boot alltag
jetzt von von den kriegsereignissen mal
ganz abgesehen er hat ihren alltag auch
sehr sehr schön
gut dargestellt
sei es jetzt die brücken besatzung sei
es die phasen nur wo man auf den gegner
auf den feind wartete was so ein buch
mit gammel 1 2 und 3 beschrieben hat das
ist das was auf frieden sowohl fahrer
nachvollziehen können wenn sie selbst
einmal über wald und selbst auf ihren
manöver gegner gewartet haben und naja
die die bedingungen des wetters haben
sich nicht geändert auf der brücke alles
wurde zu fahren im winter mit vielen
wassern uns über kommt ist immer noch
nicht das reinste vergnügen ja das
glaube ich wie lange sind sie im u boot
gefahren
ich bin und zehn jahre gut gefördert
fünf jahre als wachoffizier und fünf
jahre als kommandant und was von dieser
atmosphäre von dieser auch stinkenden
atmosphäre dort unten im u-boot wolfgang
peters sind stimmt heute noch nein wir
sprechen von anti stall nummer 55 der
welt an dem auch sie um wolfgang
petersson trauern der u-boot-kommandant
langjährige fregattenkapitän weber
hierbei bild live zum tod von wolfgang
petersson danke ihn lieben dank
die chanel war schön umschrieben auf das
buch von hollywood im u-boot wir gehen
weiter zu unserem hollywood reporter
norbert körzdörfer zum tod von wolfgang
peters norbert grüße dich herzlich was
sind deine ersten gedanken an dem tag an
dem wir erfahren haben dass wolfgang
petersson nicht mehr lebt
ja unglauben ich habe gestern abend noch
mit otto waalkes gesprochen
dann ist er kommt aus emden waren alter
freund wie wolfgang petersen als ich mit
mod kampeter sind zum letzten mal
telefoniert zu seinem achtzigsten
geburtstag wartet voller energie hat in
der akademie hat er wurde zum fitness
freak also hat jeden tag zwei stunden
bergab gemacht habt ein seiner villa
hollywood über dem pazifik hat der 16
kleine treppen diese warum das war's ein
paar kurth also jobbt er ist mit dem
fahrrad eine stunde haben strand auf und
ab gefahren aber stehen dann ist er im
tool ist er 50 bei anderen gesprungen
also er wollte seinen 85 geburtstag
feiern mit 85 freunden also es war alles
er war voller voller lebensfreude und 3
erschüttert da ist es dann versucht ihn
vor ein paar wochen noch zu erreichen
damit eher einem
geburtstag artikel zum 85 geburtstag von
dustin hoffman schreibt da war aber
nicht zu erreichen das hieße seine
ferien vermutlich war er da schon in
einer klinik wie hast du dann
tatsächlich von seinem tod erfahren
ja es ist ein abend auch und
und
überall 30 jetzt dann habe ich seine
assistentin
gemailt und ihr habt wohl es wohl in den
armen seiner frau in seiner villa
abgestorben sie ist seit 44 erwartet ja
dem aussprechen drogenkriegs das muss
man wissen dass es ein dass die cobra
des krebses ein ergibt nicht aggressiver
krebs der unheilbar ist wenn man nicht
rechtzeitig erkennen und
es muss man alles sehr schnell gegangen
sein der zuschauer für bild live märkten
gerade wie nahe die das geht norbert der
tod von wolfgang petersen das boot das
bleibt für immer das ist ein riesiges
werk noch für generationen wie sehr hat
dass deutschland auch verändert was hat
das deutschland gegeben dieses bot
dieser film
ja es war das war unvergleichlich ist
wenn ich der erste große diesen erfolg
in amerika der hatte er glaube ich sechs
oscar nominierungen und ist es immer
noch ein hollywood heißt es immer
peterson enzo bearzot zurück und es war
für die in deutschland wurde er kritisch
gesehen für amerikaner war es der anti
kriegs film schlechthin aus deutschland
über deutschland und er hat clint
eastwood jetzt schon 290 ist ein riesen
fan und freund von petersen und die
wollten jetzt auch noch zusammen ein
polizeifilm machen er hat immer
als er darüber gingen nach amerika hat
er hatte schwarzenegger getroffen der
gesagt du kannst meine bilder haben
hatte ich habe mehrere will du kannst du
haben ja aussuchen dann kannst du wohnen
dann ist er da hatte da der grund dann
hat bietet musste aber dummerweise noch
8000 dollar miete 200 und hab da fast
fünf jahre muss man zusammen ausgehalten
und an projekten gearbeitet
wird ist gut ihm gesagt hat ich mach ein
1 1 thriller insel einer feier und ich
möchte dich als rechtliche nur peters
mit dem mach das und das war es ein
großer durchbruch in amerika
später kamen die royal pid da ist ein
mann zu sehen der
director's cuts man wirklich nackt und
dann seine erfolgreichste film wohl
finanziell war air force one mit
mithelfen vorteils us präsident da war
er war der deutsche regisseurin
danke norbert körzdörfer bild hollywood
reporter dass er seine emotionalität ist
danke
[Musik]